having a very warm welcome to the World
Economic Forum dw8 coming to you from
nepeta the capital of a Myanmar who
would have thought to stay year ago that
we'd be all gathered here in this
country on the threshold of great change
a country which is currently facing huge
problems but also hopes we part of the
success story of Southeast Asia
now economic prospects in Southeast Asia
remain extremely bright but we also know
now that lack of proper infrastructure
is a big drag on growth which could be
even higher and more inclusive so what
do we need to do to power growth through
strategic infrastructure what actions
what innovations do we need to realize
the full economic potential of Southeast
Asia to discuss as we have a
distinguished panelists fair for you
here starting with Steven P Groff who's
the vice president at the Asian
Development Bank based in Manila Sheryl
sham Saleem president and group CEO of
Sapporo Kanchana petroleum from Malaysia
hey mr. Witt chief executive officer
Leighton Holdings based in Australia
John rice vice chairman GE Hongkong
who's also the co-chair of the World
Economic Forum East Asia and Gita Vijay
van the Minister of Trade from Indonesia
a warm welcome to all of you now you
could give them a hand
of course
it's even let me start with you now you
have a very broad overview of the region
through your work with the Asian
Development Bank especially in
infrastructure what do you think needs
that what are the infrastructure needs
in your assessment of this region to
unleash its full economic potential well
I'm right to first thanks for having me
here today I mean I think we all know
that the the needs of the region are
huge our estimates for developing Asia
are the needs are somewhere on the order
about 750 billion dollars a year between
now and 2020 so those are huge and those
are a range of different infrastructure
areas such as transport and
communications and energy supply but the
other part of it of course is that we
need to see interconnectedness between
Southeast Asian countries in particular
increasing and right now the connection
is the transport connections the
telecommunication connections the energy
energy supply connections between
countries in Southeast Asia are
insufficient to meet the kind of demand
to meet the kind of growth rates that we
want to see propelling the region
through for the coming decades Thank You
Steven John your company GE has been
involved in ASEAN for over a hundred
years how important is the role of the
private sector in unleashing the
potential of this region through
investments in infrastructure well I
think it's very important I think when
you look at the challenge of providing
infrastructure for a growing population
a growing middle class that really wants
better things you need you need private
companies and the technology they bring
you need you need private capital and
then you need capacity and capability
creation I mean you have to be able to
to train people and help them become
better leaders and it's really the kind
of things that you do for a country that
we would do in GE for our own people
right now obviously here miss your
company is an engineering and a company
which has been involved in
infrastructure in Asia for several
decades you're also a member of the
World Economic Forum's Infrastructure
steering committee
what areas would you highlight an
infrastructure development which are key
for the region the first thing is to
understand why what was that a committee
formed for and why and if you look at
the the major challenges that have taken
place post there GFC really is the
burden of rolling out infrastructure or
the responsibility of rolling out
infrastructure cannot rest just with
governments alone various fiscal
constraints mean that the you know we've
seen a huge shortfall and the global
shortfall of infrastructure development
is around about one trillion dollars so
at the World Economic Forum the Board of
Governors and the infrastructure sector
has really been working on on trying to
unlock the issues that are that are
causing their deficits so we're looking
at prioritizing projects we're looking
at better allocation of risks between
the public and private sector and and
finally how do we access you know this
huge amount of private funding that is
out there and really bringing that
public-private partnership together to
fund this infrastructure deficit thank
you and now you are the owner of one of
the biggest companies oil and gas
integrated services companies based in
Malaysia do you think that energy is the
biggest infrastructure issue facing the
region and if so what needs to be
addressed most urgently I would echo to
say it is it is a very critical
component of development this energy
will drive all the other developments
that that is required and it's not just
one just energy but the the interlink
and the dynamic that goes on the
different components as transport
education security and a in a strong
legal infrastructure because if when all
this comes together then then we will
also attract investment into into the
region and one of the things that we
have to be mindful about this area is
that you know different countries are at
at different levels of development I
would propose a joint development on
infrastructure itself because there will
be effective use use of capital at the
same time
also like to underscore the point that
in developing any of this facet
especially energy it's also an
opportunity to build capabilities
locally I think John mentioned about
capacity building and building a middle
class this this projects a huge is an
opportunity to Train capabilities to
grow the middle class in this area which
is on the demand side of whatever is
produced after the energy and the
transport and telecommunications without
without the development of both in
tandem you made this inter mediate
certain certain classes of people and
and it will not be a sustainable so I
guess I would add to that add to that
will be a prudent wouldn't policy that
encourages all of all of this to happen
in tandem thank you shall we get the
most of the big infrastructure projects
in in the world particularly in Asia and
the hands of the government what kind of
actions and innovations can the
government actually take or make to make
infrastructure more effective in this
region well I think let me speak with on
behalf of ASEAN we take a look at ASEAN
on the yardstick of just about
everything in the infrastructure play
whether it's the degree of
electrification the number of kilometres
of roads on a per thousand persons basis
number of kilometers of railroads on a
per thousand person basis and the
telephony and all that Asya and sort of
like rings sup visa vie you know our
friends and other parts of Asia well not
to mention the OECD countries we've
we've got our work cut out and I think
the view taking going forward ought to
be with respect to the government's will
or political work rather and that has to
be backed by a very strong fiscal fiscal
space the rule of thumb is you know for
every dollar that needs to be spent on
any infrastructure project the
government should be spending a quarter
to a third of that and the rest should
be about a private hand
but are they spending enough because the
average spend in Southeast Asia by
governments and infrastructure is below
the Asian average sure sure I mean like
whatever yardstick that I've mentioned
not only the portrait of where we are
visibly all the other countries in Asia
but what we're spending is not as high
as where it should be take a look at
Indonesia more particularly our our
logistics to GDP ratio is the highest in
the world visa fees some of the more
developed economies in Asia much less
the developed economies around the world
I think it's around the range of 20% in
terms of the cost of logistics and that
is attributable to the fact that the
infrastructure is just not adequate
we've got to spend a lot more and I
think we can't just be thinking of the
tens of billions we've got to think of
the hundreds of billions if not the
trillions in the next 10 to 20 years the
question is are we gonna have enough
fiscal space and the answer is we do
know I think with that space given
enough political will given the right
regulatory framework I think we can
start getting things moving the right
direction more so than ever
hey Mitch do you think there is enough
fiscal space because what statistics
showed that actually the amount of money
spent on infrastructure lending projects
last year declined by about six point
three percent I don't think the the
constraint is is lack of liquidity or
the fiscal constraint I think the the
issue is the risk allocation and and you
know this if we call it this
public-private partnership you know how
do we actually develop a model that out
that deals with all the risk across all
the different sectors to give the
certainty unit to the investors to get
their return over a sustainable period
and everything we're talking about here
is not one or two years with all of us
have mentioned decades and a very long
term vision towards a sustainable
productive future so for me the you know
the key is is really the model is an
equitable model that the chairs the
appropriate levels of return and risks
between public and
partnerships John is that something you
can agree with that it risk is the
problem the distribution of risk and is
there only gonna one kind of model in
private public partnership so what would
you well I think that public-private
partnership is is a term that people
tend to define a little bit differently
at its heart though I think you have to
assume that if you're going to attract
private capital to invest in a in a
public infrastructure project you have
to be prepared to deliver the investors
a certain return and for a public
company it's roughly equivalent or over
the weighted cost of capital and if you
and if you can't do that then you're
gonna not going to attract much private
capital because that capital's got to go
where the shareholders think that they
can get a reasonable risk adjusted
return and so it really starts with that
premise and i think if you can solve for
that then you have companies like ours
and others that are quite prepared to do
business around the world even in places
where you might see a higher risk
because it's a business we understand
it's with partners that we know so we
take a different view of the strategy
behind the decision but but you got a
really wrestle with the fundamental
question is can you can you give a
return provide a return that allows the
private capital a reasonable risk
adjusted return sure you what is your
experience being I I would like to echo
what what is about give an example yeah
if you look at Malaysia the development
of modular oil fields where we were able
to fund it yeah we were able to fund it
by by the banks basically we were able
to raise bond based on the certainty of
hydrocarbons in the ground and that the
project will yield a certain return
without without again without it knowing
that you will get that yield you will
not get
financing so in that way the policy was
to allow a some sort of a cat I mean
that the the risk is is guaranteed by
the company and the banks were willing
to accept the risk because the company
was in a consortium that was that a
track record of developing these fields
before the subsurface was studied by an
independent company which was endorsed
and that risk was internalized by the
finances and the finances then gave us
the money to to develop the project of
now almost a billion over dollars so
again it's the legal infrastructure the
way the way you would you would find
innovative ways of financing those kind
of projects through through a
non-traditional approaches to to the
securing of risk Stephan everybody's
talked about some of the kind of this
cheap money available for infrastructure
projects is a need for infrastructure
development from your experience is it
actually this the lack of finances which
is impeding infrastructure development
or is it the non-financial hurdles which
are much more important like the
regulatory framework the legal framework
that you talked about and multiple
layers of governance in countries like
Indonesia
the short answer the question is yes you
know I think that the challenge that the
region faces is is one of it's one of
this risk point that John has made but
it's also a lack of instruments for
intermediating the excess savings that
exists within the region and we refer to
this as the the infrastructure financing
paradox that exists within Asia broadly
but specifically within ASEAN I mean
asean right now you have some 700
billion dollars of foreign exchange
reserves and you have an unmet demand of
60 billion dollars of infrastructure
just in asean alone so unless we can
figure out instruments and mechanisms
for for leveraging against that those
those excess savings right now those
excess savings are invested in low
yielding Treasury securities in the euro
zone and in the United States
so we need to figure out ways you can
leverage that money much as the other
panelists have said to make investments
at you know appropriately risk assessed
investments in in the region now Gita do
you think the government's are doing
enough and have they got it right
because when you choose an
infrastructure project in which you want
to invest what is your primary motive is
it actually to gain revenue or is it to
actually job creation or get the maximum
number of people benefit from it well
we're not in a government to gain
revenue were the government to serve the
public right that's what we call me the
plate servant you know you've got ASEAN
with around ten kilometres of roads on a
per thousand person basis about 0.25
kilometers of railroads on a per
thousand person's basis about 75 to 76
percent elective electrification rate
relatively good quality of water
availability telephony you know the
fixed line yardstick is not I think
accurate and you know giving the right
picture because of the mobile telephony
and that has allowed us to circumvent
the impediment now I'm not a proponent
of the argument that you know the money
is an issue but the fiscal space is an
issue I've never been worried about
whether or not there's enough money out
there to fund the building of roads
railroads ports and airports and power
generation capabilities but the private
guys are not gonna go in if they don't
see the government getting its act
together no the government's made a
couple of mistakes in Indonesia you had
to say well that's probably an
understatement but you know nobody's
perfect but look I think the view
forward is that we have recognized what
our shortcomings have been and the
important thing is directionality you
know guys like John and Cheryl and Steve
and Mitch are not gonna look at
Indonesia if there is no macro
political stability if there is no macro
economic stability and I think we can
check off those two boxes today tomorrow
and a few years thereafter the ratings
are improving and all we've got to do is
just is is just that we've got to put
money on the table from the government
for a long time we don't we didn't have
that ability because we were indebted
significantly we have trimmed down our
debt now we can start thinking okay
let's put more money into education
let's put more money into infrastructure
before when we started having more money
we can do it as easily because the
regulatory framework was not ready now
it is more ready than ever because the
land law is out it tells and defines the
extent to which or how long you're gonna
have to wait to clear land and how much
you gotta pay
that's a defining moment not only for
the government but hopefully for the
private sector now all the stuff that
John and the other guys have to do is
just wait okay this guy's been talking
but is he putting money to work better
airports or more airports ports and
power generation capabilities I'm quite
sure the money will come because there
is tons of liquidity but when that's the
questions coming from ASEAN you know I'm
a student of gradualism we've just got
to be patient time is running out we
have to find out I'm gonna ask John
Indonesia is obviously making quite a
bit of an effort from what the minister
says is the story of Indonesia
replicated across Southeast Asia our
governments doing enough in terms of
infrastructure regulation in terms of
land uncertain land rights and I I don't
really know how to define enough but
governments are doing more and I think
the the point that Keita made more and
more governments understand it's
complicated there are trade-offs that go
with all of this I mean economic
development infrastructure development
doesn't come for free right and it
doesn't come without making trade-offs
you have to choose path you have to make
choices about power sources you have to
make choices about transportation you
have to relocate people to build new
roads and
and railroads and that comes at a little
bit of a price but that is the
conversation going in the right
direction I think I think it absolutely
is because underneath if I may just add
okay almost a couple of years ago John
and I were having a drink in Honolulu
he was just boggled and balked by how
slow things were and I told him to be
patient and guess what value unleashed a
couple of months thereafter and guys
like GE and the big companies around
here they get the big picture and all
they want to see is directionality and I
think Indonesia has been able to prove
directionality I think that's exactly
right and we're not we're not looking
for risk-free investments we're looking
for reasonable clarity a level playing
field and a stable governance structure
we understand as an investor you have to
take risks so it's not about that at all
it's about exactly the points that that
Gaeta made and when we see that we are
prepared to invest and we're doing that
in E in Indonesia and other countries in
Southeast Asia but what there is the
region does face is actually and the
lack of adequate electricity or what
they call energy poverty
Sharleen if you want to kind of add your
comments on that by 2015 and the ASEAN
Economic Community is supposed to come
in place energy integration is a
important element of that how far have
they got there I think the the
conversation is is progressing well
again you know I have to underscore the
the issue of trade-offs different
countries are at different levels of
development and prudent use of policy to
drive the delivery of energy to the
right to the right place and a
transportation of energy to the right to
the demand where it's at is it's a
complex one you know if you just use a
straight line capitalistic model you say
just let's send it where the demand is
but you do have to send energy to where
the demand is not yet and to ensure that
that those areas come up because in the
annual debut stretch the timeframe right
30 years those other areas are going to
need
energy so you have to start now so so
you need to have a longer term view on
this and not it's not a a three-year
five-year it's more of 15 to 25 years
this area it's probably going to be some
of the figures I see maybe 44 percent
off of the world's GDP in 25 years
but as Elise it itself a deadline and
that's one of the deadlines is 2015 and
the other deadline is 2024 an integrated
energy system Steven how much work needs
to be done we hear from Charlene it's
not an easy solution long-term planning
but do you need to say there will
nothing be able to reach the target
they've set themselves in 2020 I
wouldn't I wouldn't say that they're not
gonna meet the target but I think
there's a lot of challenges ahead I
think you look at you look even beyond
that an aggregate energy demand is
expected increase in the region between
3 to 5 percent on an annual basis so
there's there's there's meeting that de
meeting that demand creating the
interconnectedness that's necessary in
order to meet that demand on a
sustainable basis but there's other
questions if as you see that kind of
increases what is the sustainable energy
mix that we can put in place and right
now if you if we if we stay with the mix
that we have coal dependency is going to
increase by more than 50% during that
same time frame so we need to be looking
at the demand side we need to be looking
at the supply side and making sure that
we're making investments that are gonna
be sustainable in the long run
I'm not saying in any way that coal
isn't going to be part of the solution
it will be part of the solution but we
need to be looking at at addressing
energy efficiency we need to be looking
at at sustainable sources of generation
as well and ok Misha I mean at the
moment I think 74 percent of the energy
in Southeast Asia is derived from fossil
fuels what could a new energy mix look
like in this region I don't think it's
too much what a new energy mix should
look like I you know I look at obviously
the huge supply that's coming on board
with LNG and thermal coal and I think
the base load in this region it's
appropriate that comes from the fossil
fuels at this stage and as new
technologies come in you know with G
we're doing a wind farm in Mongolia at
the moment we're doing them in Australia
it's getting the the mix right but we
really need to focus on the base load at
them
and energy is you know is the is the the
foundation of infrastructure at live
what in what stimulates infrastructure
and we're seeing this huge move of
urbanization through the whole region is
just going to increase the energy demand
so whether that's fifty percent or a
hundred percent the reality is that it
can be met with today's technology in
fact G is very involved in providing
some of the solutions in Myanmar where
we are now seventy four percent of the
people have no electricity and
eighty-four in the rural areas and and I
think to the point that drill made and
others it's the fundamental building
block for for a standard of living
change in economic development you can
if you're if an ice road passes in front
of your house but you don't have
electricity you don't care so much about
the nice road right you you can't do
much without electricity in terms of
reaching all the people so for a company
like ours we've we've had to reshape how
we think about about power generation
and look at much smaller more
distributed methods because we know that
the grid won't get every where it needs
to go and reach all the people it needs
to reach and I think all of the
companies that are attending this this
economic forum have to have had to alter
their view about how to deliver products
and technology and capability in places
where there are basic needs to be met
Sharon how can the basic needs be met
from your perspective in a country like
Myanmar where the poor have absolutely
no access the rural poor to energy the
urban poor have very limited access to
energy we take certain things for
granted in the Western world
you press a switch and the light comes
on you know you turn a tap on in this
water these are things which are
completely uncertain here in this
country well you know not just this
country but all countries that are
similar yeah even Blasi at one point I
mean there are resources
yeah and those resources will be
extracted as I mentioned before in the
distraction of those resources for
energy best there's opportunities for
capacity building also and you know
those resources will also be exported
and some of the revenues coming from the
resources will have to fund social
projects because at the end of the day
you have hydrocarbons in the ground that
belongs to the country some of it it's
got to come on to development of social
infrastructures I mean there's no other
way that know me the equation is quite
big Steven I wanted a stick with a
Myanmar for a bit I mean you know we are
and this kind of moment in in the
country when it's opening up to the
world there has been a lot of investment
interest in Myanmar but on song su Chi
the leader of the Opposition warned
against a frenzy of investments and
talked about the need to be a little
more cautious in the kind of development
that Burma Burmese leaders decide to
inform what is your assessment of the
situation well I think that's I think
that's essentially correct I mean I one
think one of one of one of my greatest
concerns about about development in
Myanmar's there's a lot of challenges
and we know those we know those well
they've been articulated by many
including ourselves but I think that the
one great challenge for the countries is
that of expectations management
expectations management both on the part
of foreign investors but expectation
management perhaps even more importantly
on the part of the people of Myanmar
you know there's huge expectations for
dramatic and speedy change that are not
going to be met it's going to take time
I mean there will be change I'm
completely convinced that the government
is committed to this reform process but
it's going to take quite some time and I
think that this is why when we talk
about resource extraction is critically
important and I agree entirely with the
fact that we need to be making
investments side by side in in in social
infrastructure in an off-grid
electricity supply in in education and
health and if we don't see those
investments in happening in Myanmar
alongside resource necessary resource
extraction you know the future is not as
bright as it might otherwise be Nikita
we've seen that you know you
as a politician your country's been
through various stages of development
the other countries in this region
Vietnam Laos Cambodia they've also had
to make changes
looking at Myanmar what would you wish
for the country what would you quotient
them against and what would you say that
they shouldn't need to do as they open
up to the world
well actually I was I was uh I had a
discussion with sounds wiki last year
and some of the stuff we talked about
related to the stuff that you've just
observed
you know until about a year and a half
ago I was the chairman of the Investment
Board in Indonesia and I was I was very
careful about not overselling over
marketing Indonesia and it's always
useful to tell everybody from within and
beyond that you know there's still
corruption in Indonesia there's still
bureaucratic deadweight in Indonesia
that we're not as educated as some of
our brothers and sisters and friends in
Singapore and Malaysia but the important
thing to note is that is Indonesia going
to be less corrupt five years from today
or ten years from today is Indonesia
going to be less bureaucratic and you
know I would encourage them to take a
view and and the facts are that you know
in 2009 FDI was only about six billion
u.s. and last year we had twenty five
billion US dollars worth of FDI and FDI
has been growing at twenty-five to
thirty percent the fact remains that
three to four years ago the United
States was not even in the top fifteen
now they're in the top four Korea was
nowhere in the picture Korea is now the
second or third largest investor in
Indonesia and the good news is they're
putting money to stuff that matters in
the long run and that's not just coal
mining oil and gas and all that good
stuff it's stuff that's being put into
manufacturing services agriculture and
whatever that I think will help
Indonesia move up the value chain in
Denyce is already moving in the right
direction from what I can see again
you're very much the flavor of the year
and if I had my
the flavor of the Year congrats to you
know our friends in Indonesia is very
kind of ready to join the BRICS then I
should be called brixi Indonesia as well
I've had my debates with Jim O'Neill
yeah we you know let the others choose
as to whether or not we belong to that
group I want to touch briefly on a point
that you made about the frenzy in
Myanmar before ants answering your other
question because I I think if it's a
frenzy it's not gonna serve the the
nation well and the government can't
absorb a frenzy the decisions can't be
made if it's a frenzy I think it's
incumbent upon all of us to make sure
that it is a measured approach I think
the other point is that the the
government this this fledgling democracy
p60 million people are waiting to see
what democracy will bring and they have
to see benefits so there are gonna be
some trade-offs that have to be made
because I don't know that they're gonna
wait five or ten years to see those
benefits they're gonna need to see some
benefits soon and some benefits over
time and I think all of the companies
involved and all of the institution's
involved in this process have to respect
that fact that will require trade-offs
to the balance between short term and
long term and if we we all get this
right the there is no reason to think
that the people of Myanmar can't benefit
just the way people in other Asian
countries have benefited from good
governance democracy investments and a
better standard of living yeah the
important thing of course is responsible
investments because all the things on
sang-soo she said that people are
already getting impatient here that it's
in the third year of reform and they are
asking for basic infrastructure basic
things like roads water electricity
health education so you're right it's
also a problem about high expectations
well I think so - let's face it
democracy is not perfect there are
democracies that have been around for
hundreds of years that don't always
operate the way people would like them
to operate I think you have to
give a lot of credit to the amount of
change that's taking place here in a
relatively short period of time people
without electricity want electricity and
if you don't have it you're impatient so
I get that but but this has been
tremendous progress in a in a in almost
overnight in the context of democratic
evolution I asked Stephen wanted to talk
about the frenzy since that has become a
bit of an issue here apparently one of
the ministers reportedly said that he's
meeting so many international
delegations of investors that he has no
time to actually think about what he
should be doing what are they offering
what should I do this is this a person
to invest in and you worried about that
that there is this kind of scramble for
a rich nation with poor people for
resources here I know I think that's
exactly correct and I and I would
include you know ourselves as my as a
representative of donor the donor
community that that we contribute to the
problem as well where we you know we I
think suck up some of the bandwidth as
far as the as the far as the ministries
are concerned and it's a challenge we've
seen over and over again and in in many
emerging economies where where the
capacity in the in the in the government
is very very limited so the number of
people that you can actually see that
know what's going on is relatively
limited so I think that what we need to
be doing collectively is exercising
restraint self-restraint which we're not
necessarily that good at but it's you
know encouraging to hear John you know
emphasize the importance of that but
also I think is finding ways that we can
invest in building capacity within the
government and within institutions in
the in the country so they can actually
serve that demand the demand it's not
going to go away and there's gonna be
interest in this country for a long time
to come
but that getting over this hump in the
immediate term is going to require
restraint on the part of investors
restraint on the part of donors but also
us finding ways that we can help support
the government in in in making these
things happen over the short term Alan
is a wonderful organization you work
very well together but this also
underlying services are the kind of
values of competing with each other as
countries when it comes to
infrastructure because there has to be
connectivity and an infrastructure level
sure at the end of the session this
morning
look earlier you know John and I were
together with ashore and a few other
prominent people it was it was a
fascinating discussion about where ASEAN
is and how we're surviving I think it's
important to underline that we're we're
a different kind of Union by the way of
history and legacy visa vie some of the
other unions that we're seeing in you
know other parts of the world and I
think we're there to last it has been
miraculous how we have turned out you
know from a geopolitical economic and
social and cultural standpoint and I
think it's gonna last yes Singapore is
gonna have to do whatever they have to
do Malaysia is gonna have to do whatever
they have to do Indonesia has got to do
whatever we've got to do and I think the
next 20 years it's all about making sure
that we've got the supply side of the
equation ready and it's these guys out
here who can help us in terms of
creating and availing the splicing thank
you very much I just want to add one
point it's it's not just a frenzy in
Myanmar you know I feel like I don't
have time to think nowadays I think you
should brick see that's why well I think
that the final is very much for their
comments obviously we couldn't raise all
the issues that we could have raised and
wanted to raise but we have time
constraints may I now invite the
audience to post their questions but
gentlemen there if you would wait for
the mic to come to you
Deepika from Accenture development
partnerships there's been a lot of talk
about
ppp's and public-private partnerships
here and infrastructure a very
interesting conversation or whatever
about private private partnerships and
I'm thinking particularly where you know
rural electrification meets agriculture
meets telecoms and is there an
opportunity for the private companies to
get together in a more integrated
approach to drive both economic
development but also the social
development that we're not in maar needs
I'd just like to add the probably about
80% of our order book in Asia is
actually private to private so you know
whether it's the minds that we're
working on or you know casinos in in
Macau the tourism sector
bottling plants for coca-cola in
Indonesia factories for Caterpillar so
the bulk of the work that we do actually
is is private investment coming in but
where the deficit sits at the moment
which is what we've been focusing on is
harnessing this public-private
partnership will fund the deficit but
also now would act to the point earlier
about about legal and regulatory
frameworks and how critical those are in
order to realize whether it be public
private partnerships or private private
partnerships but also I think policy on
the part of governments and in terms of
determining that this is indeed a
priority and this is one thing they that
they want to align themselves behind and
so again it there's there's much to be
done I could actually go into new areas
we always try to do to work with with
companies that add value yeah on a
private basis on for example in in in
Brazil we go in with a with residual
with another company to address that
market in in Malaysia indeed for
development of oil fields we are and
within a company called Petrofac and in
and you get a sharing of capital a
sharing of risk and also the sharing of
expertise and capabilities to execute
the work which gives the finances the
confident confidence to come in and fund
those projects thank you I think we have
a question there from a gentleman in the
white shirt angle ah ah
my name is Oh will I'm a member of
parliament from a view constituency well
we are very proud to host a forum like
this in you are welcome to our country
what I would like to ask for is what
would you like to wish for our people
people of Emma or any message that you
want to give to us thank you very much
thank you very much thank you for
welcome us here country we're all very
happy to be here and I think this is
missing maybe everyone can say a word
I don't mind starting I
thank one of the few things that made us
the way we've turned out was there was
that there was a military reform that
took place before real political reform
and that's I think the step that you
guys are taking here already and you can
learn from not only our successes but
our mistakes and you know we're only 15
years into the game and there's more to
come but definitely Indonesia could be a
model for you to take a look at I would
agree with that and I think that there's
a there's a real advantage that Myanmar
potentially has as a second mover if you
will to look at both the positive
stories and the negative stories from
the region and and move ahead in that
and I think one thing I would underscore
is just the importance of if equality
and inclusiveness when it comes to
growth one thing that we've seen over
the region over the last 20 years is
we've seen you know tremendous amounts
of people moved out of poverty but a lot
of that has been in China and so there's
been a gap that's been growing between
the rich and the poor across the region
and that is something that that's that
the foemen social and stability foments
all sorts of different things that you
don't want so you need to be looking at
both the top end of that growth you have
to be looking importantly at the bottom
end of that growth as you move forward I
think the one thing for me is is looking
forward you know the if you look back
and you try to you know reflect on the
past and you and you can't you you can
never put that behind you but the
challenge will be to unite on a common
vision for the good of the nation and
and that's and then tap into all the
lessons learnt around the region because
you're certainly not alone in the
journey that you're taking and there's a
lot of interests that you succeed you
know my my wish is that that people will
see the benefits of democracy understand
that there needs to be some trade-offs
in order for those benefits to keep
accruing and that this process will
continue to develop and if you think
about the Indonesia analogy there were
probably people 15 years ago who were
predicting it might not work it's not
moving fast enough you know there isn't
the right benefit being spread around
and those things get dealt with over
time
I'm a little bit cautious to recommend
any cookiecutter solutions for for-4 I
guess for for the running of a country
because every place is unique and every
place have their own issues that they
have to deal with therefore you know
look at all the systems that are
available around and and understand how
those systems fit best to your own needs
and your own pace of development well
that brings us to the end of this
session
powering growth through strategic
infrastructure in Southeast Asia that
was the focus of the World Economic
Forum dw/dt coming to you from napa town
like political capital of myanmar i
thank all the panelists for their great
contributions i thank the audience here
for being attentive and i think all of
you whoever you are wherever you may be
for being with us on this wonderful
occasion i had a great time i hope you
did too
bye-bye